PATRICK HAMMAN: Oh, sorry.
I don't have any notes.
Let me just turn off
this button over here.
Brilliant.
Cheers for the intro part.
Sorry it had to be so long.
So, I'm Patrick,
and you can catch me
on Twitter, @patrickhamman.
As Paul said, I'm here
to talk to you today
about how we at the Guardian
manage to break news
within a thousand milliseconds.
And hopefully, the
true meaning of that
will be explained
throughout this talk.
So, if you haven't
guessed it already,
I work at theguardian.com,
where I'm a senior developer
and technical lead on
the core content team.
So our web team is
split into three teams.
I manage one of
them, and there I
specialize in front-end
operations and performance.
Again, as Paul mentioned,
over the last 18 months,
we've been building a new,
completely responsive website,
from the ground-up.
We did not use a single line
of code from the old system.
Completely re-architecting
the system for a new Guardian
in the future, a
Guardian that will
sustainable
throughout the future.
As Brad Frost coined
the phrase once,
of planting the responsive seed.
So, large organizations
like ourselves,
and BBC News, and some
of our other friends--
it's a very daunting and scary
fact when you turn around
to your stakeholders,
and you say,
"We are going to
throw away the whole
of the entire
previous architecture
that you've just invested
millions over the last six
years on, and we want to build
a completely new platform."
You know, they're
like, "No, no, no.
We've got to test this first."
And so, what we did, is
that we actually implemented
the responsive site on
our m-dot domain first--
on the mobile domain--
and then last year,
when we moved to
theguardian.com,
we integrated that one to
just a singled dot dot dot ,
and using some clever
routing at the CDN level.
And hopefully, over
the next two months,
it will be coming to a
desktop near you soon,
and we will be
completely turning off
the old architecture.
And as well as that,
in March of this year,
we broke 100 million unique
browsers within a single month.
And I'm very proud of this stat,
and it's a very key cornerstone
in the history of The Guardian.
And the current
platform that we had
was just not designed to cater
for this sheer amount of users.
But also, more
interestingly, we are
seeing these 100 million
users are accessing the site
from over 6 to 7,000
uniquely different devices.
Again the old
platform was just not
designed to cater for these.
We needed a better solution.
So, a very good
example of this here.
We've got the current site
on the left-hand side,
and the new, responsive
platform on the right-hand side.
The new platform managed
to render within a second,
and we're still waiting
slowly as we build the page
bit by bit, component-component
with the old site.
But what does this actually
see, what is this to the user?
How does a user really
see this in real time?
Boom.
We finished loading the
entire site in three seconds.
We're still waiting, waiting.
The current median
average for load time
on our current platform
is 10-12 seconds.
That's not acceptable.
You can see there's a
recurring theme here.
And it's not just The
Guardian's problem.
This is a great article
taken from "Web Performance
Today" in March last year.
This was taken from
e-commerce platforms,
that your average user
in 2000 expected your web
page to load within
nine seconds.
And, in 2012, that was
reduced to below two.
So again, our current platform
isn't designed for this.
But still, it's not just
The Guardian's problem.
In reality-- I digged this
up from [INAUDIBLE] archive,
and pumped the
data into BigQuery.
This is the median speed
index for the top 10,000 Alexa
websites.
You can see here that the median
average is around 9-10 seconds.
But the 90th percentile
is staggeringly
between 15-20 seconds off
the top 10,000 websites
in the world.
I was shocked when
I saw that data.
But it's not just
a Guardian problem.
We're here in the
median baseline.
We had to do
something about this.
I hope when most of you
create new products,
the first thing you do
is go and find out about,
maybe our users didn't
care about speed.
So we went out, and we
queried 3,000 of our users,
and asked them about 17
of the key product drivers
for the Guardian news site.
And they rated-- this is
very unsurprisingly to me,
but surprisingly to
a lot of stakeholders
in the business--
they rated speed
as the second-most important
factor, a key product indicator
for our platform, only
after easy-to-find content.
And you'd hope,
on a news website,
that the content
is easy to find.
So our uses do actually care.
The websites are
slowing down, and users
are asking for faster websites.
As well as taken from
the user's mouth--
this is an excerpt taken from
Ilya Grigorik's amazing book,
"High Performance
Browser Networking,"
which I think literally
everyone in this room
should go out and buy and read.
It was the best
book of this year.
So, there's a lot
of HCI research
that shows that for a user
to perceive that a machine is
actually working, they'd have
to have a response within 1,000
milliseconds.
And after 10 seconds, the
task is completely abandoned.
This doesn't just
relate to websites.
This could be me at home,
watching television,
changing a channel.
Clicking a button.
I want the machine to respond
within 1,000 milliseconds,
for me to know the machine is
working, for me to cognitively
feel that this is a fast
machine, it is responsive.
Let's look at that number
again: 1,000 milliseconds.
No longer can we
as web developers
start to think in seconds.
We must be thinking
in milliseconds.
And, both Nat and Addy here
today have shown that clearly.
We really need to be
thinking in milliseconds.
And so, what if you could
enforce this, as a budget?
As part of your
development workflow,
when we were starting
to create a website,
setting ourselves
a rendering budget.
Our site needs to render
within 1,000 milliseconds.
Both Tim [? Cadlick ?]
and Brad Frost
have been coining
this idea of having
a concept of a
performance budget,
and that is exactly
what we did at Guardian.
We call them our lines
in the sand: rules
that we are not
willing to cross.
All features must
adhere to these budgets,
to these lines in the sand.
We've actually
got a lot of them,
but I'm only going to focus
on four of them today.
For the rest of the
talk, I just want
to go through our lines
in the sand with you--
a manifesto, as such.
So the first one-- let's dive
straight in, and take a look.
One thing that we are very true
believers in at The Guardian:
we are in the content business.
That is our job.
We deliver high-quality
content to users.
Therefore, when we think
about responsive design,
we actually think of
content-first delivery,
content-first design.
That's the only Flash
animation I've got in my talk.
Think of a word for
site, a normal blog.
What happens on the server
side to actually render a page:
if user clicks on a link goes
through to read the article.
What's actually happening
in the server response
there, is normally we are
doing a database look-up
for the article itself.
Or, probably then, perform
another database look-up
for the related content
widget you've got.
Another database look-up for
your comment section, and maybe
the most popular
content at the bottom.
So, all these database
queries are building up.
On average, your Wordpress
blog will probably
bed doing six to eight
database look-ups
before it can even deliver
the content to the user.
But even though the
user only really came
to read the article-- he didn't
care about the side widgets,
or the most popular component,
or even the comments
[INAUDIBLE].
Each one of those
database requests
is eating into our 1,000
millisecond barrier.
On The Guardian-- this is
our typical architecture
of the old site-- is that we
had to perform three database
look-ups before we
could then render
to the user, each
one of these having
a tight coupled, single point
of failure to the services
that lie behind them.
So for instance, if
the commenting platform
was to fall over, so would
the rendering the website.
And I'm afraid it did,
on numerous occasions.
Each one of these creating
single points of failures
to other services, when
in fact, the user only
really came to read the news.
And so, we started to
think about different ways
of creating a service-oriented
architecture that we
can isolate these single
points of failure.
The user came to read the news.
We call this process swimlaning.
We have a line in the sand that
says, "We can only perform one
blocking database request
through our content API,
and that has to be the
primary content, the thing
that the user came there for."
The rest of the look-ups
can be done asynchronously,
progressively enhanced.
And so you look at
that diagram now:
we've created a swimlane, a
fault-tolerant system that
has no dependencies on the
other single point of failures,
or other services.
And so we can
asynchronously, progressively
enhance the most popular
component at the bottom.
And then, if the comments
section was to fail,
we still can deliver the news
within 1,000 milliseconds,
to the user, because that's
what they came here for.
So, on the new platform,
on the left hand side,
you'll see that's what
the initial payload is:
a bare-bones article, but still,
the content they came here for.
And then, eventually,
we progressively
enhance asynchronously loading
in the rest of the components,
each one of them having their
own single blocking request
rule.
If the comments don't
load, we fail gracefully.
And, to me, the
biggest thing here
is that we've been
able to deliver
a much faster,
resilient-to-failure
of other services, and we
can still deliver the news.
And for me, progressive
enhancement-- and I
went to a great
conference last Friday,
where my friend Tom from
GDS spoke-- and this really
resonated home to me.
Brad Wright at GDS
team once said this,
that "Progressive enhancement
is about resilience
as much as it is about
is about inclusiveness."
And to me, that's how I see
progressive enhancement.
We want to create
resilient systems that
are resilient to failure,
regardless of it.
The internet is
inherently--- I'm sorry,
don't know where I
was going with that.
Let's move on.
So for a system to
feel responsive,
we need to respond within
1,000 milliseconds.
We saw that as part
of Ilya's slide.
But before we do that, I want
us to take a step back, and have
a quick lesson in
Browser Rendering 101.
Nat actually did a very, very
amazing job-- much better
than I could at doing
this-- so hopefully we
can skim through a bit of it.
But, the point I
want to make here
is that having the knowledge
of how browsers actually
perform rendering--
everything from the click
on a link on the previous page,
through the critical path,
to actually painting
to your screen--
having the knowledge of
how it does that allows us
as web developers to make
a lot better decisions.
We know our application
stat very well,
but combined with the knowledge
of how the browser stat works
really allows us to make
some powerful decisions
about how we load our web pages.
So let's look at this, thinking
in mind our 1,000 millisecond
budget.
Here is a great slide, taken
from Google's page insights
resource, showing that actually,
on your average 3G connection,
600 milliseconds
minimum are already
taken up by 3G networking.
That's the look-up, and then
the through your HTTP handshake,
and then eventually, making
initial HTTP request ,
like maybe the get
request your index page,
and waiting for the response.
So that only leaves us
with 400 milliseconds
to play with as developers.
And I'm telling you-- 600
millisecond is a minimum.
On most UK 3G connections,
you can't even
beat the 1,000
millisecond barrier.
Normally much more.
Once we've done
that-- we've performed
the networking-- that's
taking up 600 milliseconds.
Once we get to the payload
back, just the html file,
we have to start
incrementally pausing the DOM.
Now, this is one of the great
things of that HTML spec,
is it actually can be
paused incrementally
as packets come in,
and we can start
to construct a
document object model.
But once we're constructing the
DOM, if we find a stylesheets
or script element, for
reasons that we're just
about to find out,
we have to stop.
We have to go back, and
perform our networking again.
Again, incurring that 600
millisecond latency-- already
blasted past our budget.
Once we've got
the stylesheet, we
can then start to construct
a CSS object model.
There is a lesson known,
just like the DOM,
it's still a tree-like
structure that
contains all of the
styles in an O -format.
But the problem is
here, is that we
have our wonderful
friend, Javascript.
Sorry, I skipped
past something a bit.
CSS can't be caused
incrementally,
because of the nature
of the cascade.
You paint, and then something
later in the cascade
will come over, and you
get this horrible flash,
and reflows and restyles.
So we have to fully
download the entire file
before we can then pause it.
But, our friend of and
foe, JavaScript, he
is so tightly coupled,
interwoven, with HTML and CSS,
that because of the
nature of JavaScript
could do a document.write--
our favorite feature
of JavaScript-- it
might amend the DOM.
It alter it in a way.
So, JavaScript blocks
DOM construction.
This is why we have the
age-old, best practice,
of making JavaScript
asynchronous,
putting it at the
bottom of the page,
making a promise
to the browser--
by using an async or
divert tag-- I know
that this JavaScript is
not going to alter the DOM.
I'm making a promise to you.
And so, we can take it
off the critical path.
But JavaScript is
tightly coupled with CSS,
because JavaScript execution
cannot proceed until we have
CSS object model, because
the JavaScript might ask
for a style of the DOM.
And then eventually, once we
have all this information,
we create a render tree, which
is the mixture of the two
of them, having all
the information,
from the top left of the screen,
top right, all the way down.
And then, we can
perform the geometry,
form layout, actually work
out the size of all of these,
and eventually
paint to the screen.
Nat's laughing,
because I probably
got a lot of that
information wrong.
NAT: No, just 'cause it's such
a horrible, complicated maching.
PATRICK HAMMAN: Yeah, and this
is quite a simple explanation
of it.
It is even a lot more
complex, and certain browsers
have different nuances.
But this is the easiest
way of simplifying that.
So, the point I'm
trying to make here
is how crucial CSS is
to your critical path.
If we look at a traditional
web page, we've got HMTL .
We then pause it.
We find the CSS, we
carry on, and then
eventually, the JavaScript
is at the bottom of the page.
Now, if we declared
to the browser
that's asynchronous
JavaScript, you've
already knocked off
400 milliseconds
off you're rendering.
And so here, this is the
tight coupling between CSS.
We cannot render until
we've completely downloaded,
performed all the networking,
and paused that CSS file.
So, we must get the CSS
down as soon as possible.
It is the only thing
on your critical path.
To me, it is the critical path.
And you might see where I'm
starting to go with this.
So what is your critical CSS?
What is the only
CSS that you need
to be able to paint the core
content your user came here
for?
But I mean, with responsive
web design, it's pretty tricky.
This concept of above the
fold no longer exists.
So, some CSS that might be
critical on my mobile device
is not critical on my desktop.
Or, the desktop actually might
need some more complex styles.
It's a very hard problem.
But is it your sharing widget?
No.
And it's not your
popular content.
You can see where I'm
probably going here.
It's nothing of the
progressively enhanced
component.
The only CSS that I really
need to render my core
content to the user is
what they can came there
for-- the article.
And maybe a bit of the Chrome
at the top, the navigation.
So what if we were
to inline that CSS
into the head of the
document, negating the need
to perform the 600
millisecond networking for it?
If we had all of the information
to render that core content
within the initial payload,
the first HTTP request,
we are creating the
most resilient system,
because we only need one
HTTP request to render
the thing that the
user came here for.
The browser wouldn't have
to do any more networking.
That's exactly what we
started to do at The Guardian.
We started to inline
the critical CSS
into the head of our document.
This goes against
everything that we've
been taught, of separation
of concerns, styles in CSS,
behavior in JavaScript.
It's a very weird
concept to get around,
but when you see the results,
that you're going through
in a second, it's astonishing.
Now, I'm going to
mention some tools later
that people like Addy
are spearheading, is
that you can automate
the process of this.
We choose not to automate
the process of it,
because of the tricky
problem that I mentioned,
of that what is above the fold?
We as application developers
are the best people
to make that decision.
So, we started off
with one head file.
We've now got about four
different head files.
We use Sass to do this, so that
we can maintain the modules,
include them back into
a single head file,
and then get ourselves our
code to do a bit of I/O,
read the file, and
just inject it out
as a string inside
of style element.
So let's see how the user
perceives this change.
On the bottom is with
inline CSS, boom.
Within 600 milliseconds,
we've rendered that.
We've nearly finished
rendering the page,
and the first one
hasn't even started.
Unfortunately, its with David
Cameron's head in it there.
So, at the bottom of the page,
the observant in the room
would have we realized,
"Hang on a second.
You're still gonna have to
load in the rest of the styles.
You can't just have a
bare-boned bit of CSS there."
Now, at the foot
of our document,
we asynchronously load in the
rest of the global styles.
So we're doing that here.
If we get a 200 response,
we do two things.
First, we inline
the CSS instantly,
so we have an instant rendering.
Although, albeit, maybe a
flash of unstyled content,
because we've instantly painted
with the inline at the top.
We then load in the rest.
That's obviously going to
cause a massive reflow.
So to get around that
issue, we actually
then store the CSS
in local storage.
We're using the MD5
hash of the file
to do a bit of simple
caching validation.
And then, as you'll see
on the next time road,
on the second load,
we can instantly
ask: "Does the user
already have the rest
of the global styles in
their local storage?"
If yes, boom.
We then have all of the
styles-- not even just
the critical styles-- all
of the styles of the page,
within the initial payload.
Some of the pioneers
of this technique,
which has actually
been in Google.
Steve [? Style ?] just wrote
an article dating back to 2011,
when he started noticing
that the service giants were
using this technique.
They actually use a cookie
to say that the user already
has it in its cache.
And the only reason why we
don't use that technique
is that we maintain a very
strict no-cookie policy.
We don't do any
dynamic rendering,
so that we can cache all of our
HTML on the edge, in the CDN.
So that's why we we've
opted for local storage,
but I'm very open to hearing
other people's approaches
to this.
Here, we've got our
traditional waterfall again.
So we're rendering
over our budget.
We've still got the classic
three-pronged autofill.
Now, because we've made our
CSS loading asynchronous--
it's going on in the
background-- the browser has
instant, there's the
start render event,
shaving off nearly 500
milliseconds of our rendering,
because we've managed to inline
our CSS into the document,
breaking the 1,000
millisecond barrier.
So now, if you were to
load our website today,
you will notice that
in your dev tools,
there will be no
stylesheets loaded.
But, you will see a string
in your local storage.
As I mentioned, there's a lot
of people pioneering this.
The speed module from ngx
does it on the fly for you.
Again, one of the main
reasons why we didn't use that
is because of cacheing purposes.
And Addy's written a very
great tool called Critical,
and I highly advise
you check this out.
So, automate this
as part of your
build process inside
Grunt and Gulp.
And Jonas has also written a
different approach to that,
using Penthouse, using
Phantom headless browser,
to render your page to determine
what is the critical CSS.
That's all well and good,
but surely this is a hack.
We shouldn't be
having to do this.
And so what does the future hold
for us, to be able to do this?
The first one is http/2.
It's an IETF working
draft that should
be finalized by the
end of this year.
Maybe other people
in the room that
might be able to
tell me differently.
But, the main thing
about http/2 is it
allows multiple
concurrent connections
on the same connection.
But, more importantly,
there's a great new feature
could Server Push.
So, you as a web
application developer
know more about your application
than the browser done.
What if you knew the next
file that the browser's gonna
instantly ask for
is the CSS file?
What if when we initially
requested the HTML file,
we could also push
the CSS, saying
"I know you're going to
need this, so have it.
And maybe you've even
got in your cache."
So, this paradigm of
having to load the HTML,
and then go on later
to CSS, and only then
do we have enough
information to render.
In http/2, instead of a
push, we can instantly
push both files
down the same time.
You've seen that we've
designed a system
to be resilient failure.
We now enforce
that every feature
has to be resilient
failure that we build.
I'm sure you've all seen this,
probably on a daily basis.
I know, being a kind of
semi Google-sponsored event,
I'm not saying that
it's Google's fault
in any way at all-- is anyone's
fault-- it just so happened
that that was the slide.
I should have
edited that before.
But this really is the
story of my life, OK?
I do a lot of commuting.
I'm on the train,
I'm on Twitter,
someone sends a cool
link, I click on it.
I have enough network to get
the HTML file-- but boom,
I go into a tunnel--
and my browser
has now realized that
there's some custom web
fonts on that page.
And then it has to
go and perform them,
and it's blocking.
It's not gonna render,
even though I've
got all the content.
I just want to read the content.
I don't really care what
it looks like that much.
And so, annoyingly, I
don't get to see it.
I just get a white page.
But the browser is actually
probably doing the right thing,
according to the specs.
It's slightly misleading,
if you ask me,
but it says that "user
agents may render text,"
as if it would be
rendered if downloadable.
"Font resources
are not available,
or they may render
text transparently
with a fallback font," to avoid
a flash of unstyled content.
"In cases where the
font download fails,
user agents must
display the text,
simply leaving transfer
text is considered
to be non-conformant."
Now, it is our wonderful
browser ecosystem,
and surely not everyone's going
to implement the same way.
So this table was actually
taken from a friend of mine
who is in the audience.
He wrote a very
good post, titled,
"Web Fonts and Critical
Path," by Ian Feather
from Lonely Planet.
But, you'll see here that
every browser's deeming it
slightly differently.
So, IE doesn't block at all,
and it doesn't have a timeout.
Firefox does block, and it
has a three-second timeout.
And Blink and Webkit do block,
but don't have a timeout.
Although, they might have
changed in recent versions.
But, why am I
talking about this?
And this is a very
contentious subject.
A lot of people
say that web fonts
aren't crucial to content.
I've argued throughout this
talk that the user to see also
the article, Why should they
block on a certain resource?
problem for us is
The Guardian, is
that we are in the
content business.
We are traditionally
a newspaper,
that our content was
printed on paper,
and the only thing that makes
The Guardian brand stand out
against any other
newspaper is our typeface.
And back in 2006, when we
were doing the major Guardian,
rebrand, we commissioned
a font foundry
to make a beautiful,
Guardian Egyptian font.
And if you showed
someone the website,
with or without the
font, they can instantly
recognize that it's
the Guardian brand.
So to us, when we were were
developing the project,
we were like, "We do want that.
It is part of our brand."
But, going back to that idea
of progressive enhancement,
are phones really a
first class citizen?
We didn't think so.
Especially when we've got a line
in the sand of breaking news
within 1,000 milliseconds
, surely we won't be able
to force the user to block.
We want them to fail gracefully.
Andy Hume, who now
works at Twitter,
and he was our client-side
architect at the time,
came up with this idea of fonts
as a progressive enhancement.
What if we could progressively
enhance the page,
and not cause the user
to block rendering?
So that's what we do.
The first thing we do, is
we asked whether or not
the browser is a modern browser.
We use the BBC'S "cutting
the mustard" test.
So, if it's not then
showing the fallback font,
we don't really care.
Do they support WOFF?
Do they support
modern font files?
If not, they can have
the fallback font.
If the font's in local
storage, if so, great.
Let's use it, let's
render, let's go.
If not, do we have enough
local storage space?
We'll then download
a single JSON file.
And we'll talk about
this in a second.
Once we've got that, we
store it in local storage,
and then eventually, we
can then render again.
Never blocking rendering.
Avoiding that flash of fallback.
But, more importantly,
reducing HTTP requests,
for maybe five or six font
requests, down to a single HTTP
request, and caching that
aggressively, in local storage.
And so, what we do is,
we actually base-64
encoding the font file into
string, with the key being
the font name, and then
the value being-- now,
yes, I know that base-64
encoding a font file
is actually going to
increase it in size,
but the trade off here for us is
having that one resilient HTTP
request, rather than multiple
that can take longer.
And we can actually
catch that aggressively
inside local storage.
And so we opensource that, as
with most of the things we do.
So you can check out
the MPM package web font
JSON, or the Grunt web font.
But again, there must be
a better solution to this.
The first one is the
font loading spec.
This is actually being
implemented in JavaScript.
I know Chrome would
definitely work in it.
Jake actually has got
a great post on it.
But the most exciting
to me of this,
is it uses the new
native DOM Promises API,
so that you can
actually use promises
to do things with events.
We have a lot more greater
power over controlling
when and when not do fonts get
loaded, and what to do in cases
and fall back events.
All with native Promises.
So it's amazing, allowed
us much finer control.
But this is probably one of
the most important things
I'm going to to say
tonight, is ServiceWorker.
To me, this combined
with http/2,
are literally the
most important things
coming to the webstack
over the next five years.
This is going to literally
revolutionize, and change
the way we develop
web applications.
And, as I mentioned at
the beginning, for me,
progressive enhancement
is resilience.
And ServiceWorker is designed
for an offline world,
having offline-first
web applications.
But for me, more
importantly, it's
about having resilient
web applications.
Ones that don't care about
the networking, don't care
about the network
stuff-- will always still
be able to render, regardless
of the location you are,
or whether or not
you have network.
ServiceWorker is a
separate process,
one that's intercepting every
single one of the networking
requests on the page.
And then, you can actually
decide whether or not
you want to respond
from network,
or respond from a cache.
So, we now have
new cache objects
coming to JavaScript-- much
more advanced caches that
will be able to store
items, and retrieve them,
based on certain keys.
Imagine my CSS is
in local storage,
my font's in local storage.
Now I can actually have a
place where I can cache this.
But, more reliably,
decide whether or not
we actually want to go
back onto the network,
if the user has it, or
return from a cache,
even while I'm still offline.
The final point here I want to
make is it's all well and good
developing in your
controlled environment,
with your 16 gigs
of MacBook Pro,
of with that T1 connection
that your office has got .
What are your real users seeing?
How are these features
performing in production?
How do you know if a
resources is failing?
We do that with lots
of strict monitoring.
The first thing is, as you
saw with the CSS in-lining,
one thing I
mentioned was that we
have to restrict
that file to 14 kb.
A lot of you know about the
networking stat is obviously
the first part the connection
window in the first few TCP
packets, that we must maintain a
small enough file that it's not
actually going to be
detrimental to our payload.
My developers, I
saw them a lot kind
of going, "That's
all well and good,
but how are we going to
stick inside of this budge?"
So, I wrote a Grunt
task, the NICI server,
it monitors the size of
all of our static assets,
and pinging back to
an Amazon CloudWatch
the raw and GZIP
file size of that.
So, then I could use
CloudWatch's fresh holding
and alerting on
that, to I literally
get an email when we
commit some code that
breaks the CSS past
its 14k budget.
Because I found
myself quite a lot
of having to keep a watchful
eye on our pull requests
on GitHub, of saying "Is
your feature really critical?
Does it need to be
inlined in the head?
Is it about the fold?
Are users really going to
interact with that instantly?
But now, I have a
system that tells me
when we've broken that budget.
And so, real user metrics.
Having synthetic
analysis is good,
but knowing when
and how something's
broken in production,
or how fast your site is
is in production in
real time, has literally
been invaluable to us.
We use the navigation
timing API to beacon back.
We have an in-house
analytics tool, called Ophan,
that was actually a system
designed for the editorial tool
team, based of one
of our Hack Days,
but then turned into a
fully-fledged product.
It allows the journalist to
see what content is trending
in real time, where
referrals are coming from,
what was recently published.
They use it as their
day-to-day [INAUDIBLE].
But we were beaconing
back information,
so as engineers we were
like, "Hang on a second.
We're missing a trick here.
We can add some of our
own data to that request,
and they'll never know."
So, we started using
the navigation timing
API that exposes all
of the timing data,
down to the millisecond
of the core loading
events for the page.
So, your DNS lookup, all the
way through to your final load
event.
There's a lot of great
third-party tools out here.
You don't have to
just roll your own.
Here, you can see our
median average is perfectly
staying underneath
our 1k budget.
Compared to the
old website, which
got its horrible
12-second media load time,
in its four-second
DOM content ready.
In real time, more
importantly, I
can know if a deployment
that I've just made
has affected our performance.
This is one of our developers.
Two weeks ago, we
started unloaded WOFF 2.
So, it's actually only supported
by Chrome at the moment.
But, we could filter to see by
device, by user in [INAUDIBLE]
Chrome, and instantly see
the impact that had on users.
And amazingly, because of the
way that WOFF 2 is constructed,
you actually get a lot
smaller file sizes,
we managed to shave
off 400 milliseconds,
just by doing that
changed to our fonts.
But, knowing in real
time how we did it.
This isn't really
about performance,
but I sneaked it in
here, because it's
one of my favorite
tools at the moment.
This is called Century.
We wanted to know how our
JavaScript was performing
in production, and
if it was breaking.
You can never test on
every single permutation
of JavaScript engine device,
and operating system,
and browser, even if you've
got a fully-fleshed device lab.
There's no way that you'll
be able to test on every one.
So, what if you were to monkey
patch window [INAUDIBLE]
on error, catching all of
the events, and beaconing
them back to a server
so that you can then
aggregate those results.
This is exactly what
Century does for us.
I can now, in real
time, get an alert
if we introduce a new
JavaScript error in production
that we might not have caught
for unit testing or integration
testing.
Give me a breakdown of the
browsers that it's happening
on, the build number of our
server that's happening on it,
but the most amazing
thing is literally,
it gives me a stack trace.
It tells me where
in my code base
the JavaScript
error's being thrown.
Through the next resource
maps, we can now even
get that back to
a single module.
Again, your system telling
you of its own ill health,
automating this.
It's amazing.
I mentioned [INAUDIBLE]
and monitoring,
but obviously there's always a
place for synthetic analysis,
so you can track your trends
and outliers over time.
For this, we use SpeedCurve.
The greatest thing
about it has been
how we expose it
to the business,
or how by default it exposes
itself to the business.
We made sure, as a
team that actually,
rather than just
it going to myself,
it goes through a distribution
list for the whole department.
So, we get a weekly email every
Monday morning from SpeedCurve,
telling us how our site
performed over the last two
weeks.
This makes everyone accountable
for the change, which
is extremely
important when you're
trying to change performance
culture within a business.
So, the great thing here is
that I might have not noticed
that we've actually gone up with
our median load time last week,
but then my product
[INAUDIBLE] on a Monday morning
gets an email saying
that, and he can instantly
email me saying, "Hang
on a second Patrick.
What we did last week?"
This has been invaluable.
And lastly, once you're
getting and gathering
all this metric
data please, make
sure to set alerts
and thresholds on it.
Your thresholds will probably
be wrong the first few times--
with kind of outliers,
and boy-who-cries-wolf--
but with this, you'll
be able to tell them,
and then know instantly if
you've broken your performance
budget.
Again, last section: what does
the future hold for us on this?
The first one is, not
timing API is great,
but for security
reasons, only gives you
access to the initial
HTML document.
But what you surely
want to measure,
all of maybe the third parties,
or using the Facebook API,
you want to know
when that breaks.
Or even our own services that
I'm progressively enhancing in:
how do I know if one of
those features dies out?
So, we've got a new
resource timing API,
applying a header
to those resources,
it tells the
browser, "Yep, you're
safe to give this
user in his JavaScript
the timing information
for these requests."
So then again, you beacon them
back into real-user monitoring.
Set your alerts, so
you can even when
you're external services or
internal services go down.
And lastly, the Beacon API.
This is one of my favorite APIs.
So, we're gathering
all this data--
and unfortunately,
the pure nature
of analytics, the old hack
has been using an image tag
to send these
quick, simple, dirty
get requests, or post requests.
Beacon API allows you to
make asynchronous requests.
So, you tell the
browser, "Right, I
want you to send off all this
metric data back to my service,
but I don't care when you
perform the networking for it."
Or, more importantly,
let the browser
decide when it
has networking for
And that's very
crucial on mobile,
because the browser knows
when the radio is active,
but you as a web
developer don't.
My final point is that having
these lines in the sand
has enabled us to create a
conversation with everyone
in the company, be it a
designer, a product-owner,
a stakeholder, or
third parties even.
It allows us to say, no
"No, we can't actually
do the design for
that feature that way,
because it will break
this line in the sand."
It allows you to start
having these conversations,
creating rules around.
Them
And, if you're going
to stay for the pub
I'd be really interested
to hear if any of you
have got the same rules.
Or, tell me about how
you're implementing budgets
within inside your
organizations.
So finally, here's some
takeaways and things
that I've learned along the way.
Everyone must be involved
in baking performance
into your workflow from day on."
This is not something
that you can retrofit.
It's not something
you can chuck over
the wall to your operations
team, "Don't worry,
they'll sort out the
performance problems."
Performance is a
first class citizen.
It must be part of
all discussions you
have for new
features, and everyone
should be held accountable
for change in performance.
I hope this resonated
throughout my talk--
just deliver your
core content first ,
and then progressively
enhance the rest of it.
Set a performance budget, but
measure, optimize, and repeat.
Constantly, right?
And again, it's not
something that you can just
do now for a month: "We'll focus
on performance for two weeks.
It's gonna make it fast."
Your site will slow down .
I promise you that.
That's the nature of
building software.
Products do slow down,
so you have to constantly
be measuring, and
optimizing, and repeating.
One of my favorite quotes
from Paul is, "Don't guess it,
test it."
Isn't that right, Paul?
PAUL: Yes.
PATRICK HAMMAN:
And the final point
is, it is the requirement.
It's not a feature.
Thank you.
The whole project
is open on GitHub,
so if you want to find
out more about the code,
and how we're doing it,
go and check it out there,
and you can touch my
slides at that URL.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: So, you load
the content in last, right?
PATRICK HAMMAN: Yeah (CHUCKLES).
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you,
again, so much for coming out.
Sorry it;s run on a
little bit longer tonight,
but I hope you've
enjoyed yourselves.
If you can, do
join us at the pub,
and if you just give our
speakers-- Addy, Nat,
and Patrick-- one more of
applause, that would be great.
Thank you. [APPLAUSE]